Speaker 1: All right.
Let's get into the mail bag one day early
because of our slightly different schedule
this week.
You can email info at David Pakman dot com
if you have an email question comment concern.
Many such examples for you today, starting
with someone who's just very, very angry and
I think probably has a lot more going on personally
than maybe they mentioned in this email.
Nathan wrote in and Nathan wrote, You lie
about Trump because you have no fact checking.
Why do you make money off your lies?
So you support everything Trump is for?
He at least kept us safe.
Put Diaz in charge to convict drug dealers
that bring car fentanyl into our country should
be executed.
They are killing innocent people knowingly.
That was one sentence.
You want to be a true podcaster?
Have me as another podcaster.
That is debatable to you on live every time
you're on having a podcast, even though he's
not the best at the truth necessarily.
You think Biden has told one truth or been
transparent?
Speaker 2: Nope.
Speaker 1: He said he is a middle of the road
Democrat.
Turns out he's a bigger socialist than Bernie.
Stop hating USA and start acting like you
live in America.
Because either go back to where you were and
live there or support the country you live
in now gas, food, crime, etc..
What's wrong with you?
At least Trump can hold the speech without
forgetting where he is, what he's speaking
about, and understand what the heck he is
saying.
Support our country, your standing it.
These are all the wrong your.
By the way, you're a microphone warrior.
Couldn't stand up for USA troops and look
at all the problems this country has right
now.
Just be a human, not a not a damn liberal
for a minute.
I'm not a Republican and you're calling Republicans
dumb and stupid and nuts, etc..
What's the matter with you?
I'm bored watching you say Trump's board is
pathetic.
What's better than Trump Rally?
You're making your dime off his fantasies.
I don't see you covering Joe Biden anything.
You're impressive to want a crime ridden president
that has not kept one single promise.
And Trump kept all and some.
Email me if you want to debate you on your
podcasts.
I'm definitely getting into this line of work
now that I see your pathetic lies.
If I have time, which I will make time.
You don't care that you're deciding to only
like half the country or more, actually, with
all your side coming to the Republican side,
and I am not necessarily a Republican, but
versus Biden, I am.
He's terrible.
Hope you get brighter.
Wishing you the best from the middle of the
road.
That is apparently not a Republican, but an
enlightened centrist of some kind presented
with no further comment because I feel like
I have a brain injury when I read it.
Gregg wrote in about motive.
Gregg said If Trump stole classified documents
from the White House, what would his motive
have been for committing this crime?
It's a valid question.
There have been many cases of people stealing
classified government documents.
Do you think there's a simple explanation
like the others?
Did he plan to make money by selling the documents
to Russia?
That's Greg from Costa Rica.
This is a great question to which I have not
heard a satisfactory answer.
What did Trump plan to do with those documents?
What did he plan to do?
And certainly, you know, we could speculate
about what Greg is writing here, but I just
don't have the answer.
And with Trump, the real answer could be anything.
If you think you have an idea what Trump plan
to do with the documents.
Let me know because I have no clue.
Steve wrote in, I am so sick of hearing about
the FBI searching Trump's place being unprecedented.
Who cares?
How does something become president precedented?
It has to happen for a first time at some
point, right?
The level of sheer ignorance is beyond belief.
Yeah, I've talked about this.
The fact that this has not happened to a president
before tells us nothing about whether it's
the right or wrong thing to do, whether it's
legal or illegal, and whether or not Trump
is a criminal.
Everything happens for the first time sometime.
Everything that has happened at some point
was happening for the first time.
And what certainly is unprecedented is a president
that did all the things that Trump did and
flouted every norm rule and apparently even
some laws.
So Steve is absolutely right.
This entire.
They've never done this to a president before
thing and therefore it must be wrong is logically
fallacious and it certainly doesn't pass the
sniff test.
Next email is from Lisa.
Lisa wrote in about the Secret Service in
Mar a Lago and says, David.
Is it possible that if in fact, the FBI found
nothing in Donald Trump's safe, that perhaps
he was forewarned by his loyal Secret Service
agents that contents of his safe were wanted?
What are your thoughts?
Yeah, you know, on the night of the raid,
the of the search warrant being executed,
I'm trying to be more accurate about that.
Eric Trump went on TV on Fox News.
We covered it live and said there was nothing
in the safe.
Now, he may have simply been lying, but if
it's true that there was nothing in the safe,
I would immediately start wondering whether
the documents were just moved.
I mean, it's just completely natural, obvious
question to ask.
And clearly any investigator worth their salt,
like the FBI has, many of would realize that.
So we don't even know if it's true that the
safe was empty.
Since then, everybody stopped talking about
the safe was empty.
So it might have been yet another lie just
told on the day of.
But of course, if the safe is empty.
Who might have warned Trump and where did
they move the documents is a perfectly reasonable
question to ask.
Brandon wrote in about Kinzinger for president
Kinzinger being the retiring Republican congressman,
Adam Kinzinger, who is not a pro-Trump Republican.
Brandon says, Dear Sir, as I discuss as discussed
in one of your recent shows, the Democrats
offer slim pickings for a presidential candidate
in the event that Biden doesn't run.
What about Adam Kinzinger?
What better Democrat to beat Trump or DeSantis
than a Republican's antidote?
So first of all, I haven't said that there
are slim pickings.
I think that there are great people in the
Democratic Party.
They aren't the uber progressives, but there
are some really good politicians in the Democratic
Party.
People are talking now about Gavin Newsom.
I'm not like a fan of Gavin Newsom, but I
recognize a very skilled politician.
I think Pete Buttigieg would crush anybody
in one on one debates the way he's crushed
his Fox News appearances.
I think Jamie Raskin is fantastic.
I think Jon Ossoff is a guy with a bright
future.
Stacey Abrams is interesting to me.
I don't think it's Slim Pickens on the Democratic
side.
That's number one.
Number two, there are plenty of actual Democrats
to choose from.
I don't see why we would go with the retiring
Republican for the Democratic nominee.
It just doesn't make any sense to me.
So I get what you're saying, Brandon.
Maybe Republicans would say, hey, look, here's
a Republican, but he's running as a Democrat.
I'll vote for him.
It sounds muddled and it doesn't sound like
a good idea.
Trina wrote in and Trina says about right
wing trolls versus left wing trolls.
Sir, after seeing the beautiful message you
received containing all those F-bombs, I started
to wonder how often that happens on the other
side.
Admittedly, I don't follow many right wing
accounts, but it seems the ratio of right
wingers trolling left wingers would be exponentially.
Larger than that of left wingers engaging
in the same behavior.
I suppose it would make sense as the right
seems far more likely to commit violence based
on political ideology.
But I'm curious nonetheless.
Are you aware of any reputable studies on
this topic?
Thanks for continuing to tell the truth each
day, no matter who trolls you.
So I don't have any studies that I was able
to find about whether left versus right wing
trolling of right versus left wing content
creators empirically has been has been quantified.
I don't know about that.
I can only speak to the stuff I receive.
What I can tell you is that when you look
at propensity to violence, politically motivated
violence in the United States is almost exclusively
right wing.
The right often will deny that.
They'll say, you're mis categorizing some
of it, or what about entre fire or whatever
else they come up with?
But the truth is that when you look at politically
motivated violence in the United States, if
you want to find it on the left, it's the
occasional what's called eco terrorism.
And it's relatively rare.
The violence is mostly on the right that we
know for sure.
Peter wrote in and says, How can I request
to be gifted a membership via the website?
Beautiful question.
Every week I get ten emails from people saying,
David, please put me on the list for a free
membership.
And as I've said probably 100 times, you can't
get on the list by emailing me.
You must follow these extraordinarily simple
instructions.
If you want a free membership, we have a waiting
list.
It simply goes in order.
You go to David Pakman dot com slash free
membership.
Okay.
Peter David Pakman dot com slash free membership.
You will be asked your name and your email.
That's all we need to get you a free membership.
We currently have 800 people waiting.
I know that sounds like a lot, but we've already
gifted over a thousand memberships, so it
actually does move relatively quickly.
David Pakman dot com slash free membership.
Do not email me.
John wrote in about due process and John says,
Dear Mr. Pacman, I don't understand how people
on the left cheered about the deaths of bin
Laden and al-Zawahiri.
Proper procedure would require that they be
captured alive, extradited to the U.S. and
tried in court before any punishment could
be imposed.
No jury has seen any evidence nor heard any
legal arguments in support of any punishment.
I feel that we U.S. citizens have been made
party to an extralegal assassination of potentially
innocent men.
Citizen, potentially innocent.
I just don't buy in the court of public opinion.
These these guys were guilty of sin.
But I agree with the point about due process
and I've expressed this concern before and
others on the left have as well.
When I say that Joe Biden has an accomplishment
to his name this year of ordering a successful
strike against Ayman al-Zawahiri.
I don't say that as if there's no controversy
about the total lack of due process.
I've mentioned it multiple times.
There's a complete lack of due process.
That's absolutely true.
And as progressives, it is right for us to
be concerned about that.
And I recognize that when you are a most wanted
terrorist and as a president, you're able
to take them out, to use, of course, language
that it is seen as an accomplishment.
So.
Fine progressives that don't care about the
due process part, but I absolutely care about
the due process part of that.
Jack wrote in about electric cars.
And as I say, David, I never get tired of
the Republican dumb blond joke.
Marjorie Taylor.
GREENE Her rant against electric cars was
a classic.
The marketplace is deciding.
Nobody's forcing anyone to buy an electric
car.
If all of America decided to drive a diesel
four by four pickup, it would be just as bad.
The price of diesel fuel would go way up.
Pollution would go way up.
But hey, the oil companies would make even
more profit.
Oh, wait.
The dumb blond joke is mad about the price
of gas and diesel going up as the big oil
companies gouge.
Poor, silly Marjorie.
Yeah, you know, I don't know that we need
the dumb blond stuff, but it is absolutely
true.
Marjorie Taylor GREENE last week tried to
make the argument if everybody wanted an electric
car, the electrical grid wouldn't be able
to keep up.
Well, everybody can't get an electric car.
Most of the electric cars on the market have
waiting lists.
So we know what the adoption rate could be
of electric vehicles.
And there's a plan in place for the electrical
grid to, in parallel with that, have increased
supply.
The point Jack makes is a really good one.
If everybody switched to diesel cars, there
wouldn't be enough diesel and diesel would
be astronomically priced.
Absolutely correct.
And the vendetta that some of these people
seem to have against electric vehicles, much
of it comes from ignorance and it comes from
political bias.
They're just it sounds like a sort of green
new deal.
What?
AOC has a Tesla.
It must be bad.
And it's mostly ignorance and confusion.
And actually, I would say ignorance and confusion
is sort of the theme of people like Marjorie
Taylor GREENE.
Info at David Pakman dot com with your questions,
comments and concerns.
We will see you on the bonus show momentarily.